alors je suis là pour bamako zh pour lui
mais surtout pour son petit garçon de
six ans
qui regardent actuellement quand il
s'appelle kélian qu'il y a on embrasse
fort et qui est tellement fière de son
papa cesson c'est son super héros il
peut et il était tellement proches et
sont ils trop ça présentement ça fait
bizarre
mais on connaît les risques en tant que
femme en tant que parent on de pompiers
de paris
mais on ne s'attend pas
excusez moi mais aucun problème à les
perdre pour de la négligence
ce jour là ils s'attendaient pas et
d'ailleurs il n'a pas compris ce qui lui
arrivait
on sait qu'on peut les perdre moi ce
matin là il m'a pas envoyé de message
habituellement tous les matins j'avais
un petit message de sa part pour me dire
voilà qu'il est élevé et qu'il partait
france aille bien
et ce jour là rien je me suis inquiété
et la première chose que j'ai fait en me
levant c'est que j'ai allumé la télé mon
père qui avait pour habitude de regarder
bfm la première chaîne qui s'affiche et
bfm et en fait j'ai appris par bfm
l'explosion en connaissant le secteur de
mon compagnon et à chacune de ces
veilles de garde videmment toujours le
poste qu'il a donc conducteur ce jour là
je me suis dit tout de suite et je sais
pas pourquoi je n'ai ressenti au plus
profond de moi je me suis dit ben il
niait et j'ai pris cette décision
d'appeler la caserne qui est quand même
une enceinte militaire donc on croit pas
une décision comme ça à la légère
surtout qu'il a toujours demandé de pas
le faire ce qui est normal et là je sais
pas pourquoi j'ai dit il faut que je le
fasse et effectivement heureusement que
je les fais parce que umar je tombe sur
quelqu'un tout de suite si mac essayé de
me réconforter comme il pouvait
on trouvait pas nathanel effectivement
signé terme on savait pas où il était et
puis à deuxième m'appelle pour me dire
que nathanaël et dans l'hélicoptère qui
les transportait à l'hôpital militaire
de béja
et puis hein et puis quelques minutes
après je passe le téléphone à ma belle
mère parce qu impossible pour moi de me
dire que là on va me dire je sais ce
qu'on va me dire je il en avait cardio
respiratoire il a été soufflé il a été
retrouvé en cas triste cette voiture
et on m'a dit c'est fini
voilà
et aujourd'hui je me bats pour son petit
garçon de six ans qui n'aurait jamais dû
perdre son papa aujourd'hui mais on a
dans sept explosions quatre morts
quatre orphelins
et c'est dur parce que encore une fois
ça aurait dû être évitée parce que
depuis 2015 on sait c'est ça on sait ce
qui se passe si les problèmes qu'il y
ait en fait
exactement et ce faisant elle a eu lieu
à cause d'une fuite d'eau de 2015 2015
l'année de la naissance de cayenne sont
ces vies brisées à cause d'une simple
fuite d'eau qui auraient pu être traités
correctement et puis au final on se
retrouve à des enfants en s'emparant des
handicapés à vie qui va tourner dit
détruites et
avec sa passe est un jour ça va aller
des riverains qui sont à la rue depuis
trois ans qui paye le loyer de chez eux
alors qu'ils n'y habite plus si qui
savent pas si un jour ils pourront
retourner chez eux enfin si mais c'est
c'est quoi cet amour dont ça fait trois
ans qu'on essaye de se faire entendre et
qu'on n'y arrive pas et c'est toujours